[Música]
alexis y mis primas
y siempre me muero by women at a
stanford económica
[Música]
serpa la milla que disipa de jong
aunque
no hay equipo
no vamos a pasar pero primero
gracias
bueno lo que acaban de ver es el enchufe
tm cuáles son vídeos cortos que cuentan
estas historias vergonzosas por las que
todos hemos pasado cómo comprar condones
por primera vez tu primera menstruación
perder la virginidad o reencontrarse con
tu ex
yo soy cuyo cofundador y director y
director creativo de tu ser fins y
enchufe tv el primer día que yo entré
estudiar cine mi maestro por si por
cierto un gran maestro me dijo si está
aquí para que algún día les llamen los
gringos pueden seguir cualquier otra
cosa los gringos nunca les van a llamar
pero bueno este era mi vida hacer vídeos
hacía vídeos en los recreos del colegio
después de clases en los feriados el
club y el elenco era mi hermana mis
papás mis tíos mis primos mis vecinos
hasta el perros y nadie quería
porque de verdad no me importaba ni
madrugadas ni hambre ni sed ni sueño
porque eso es lo que pasa cuando uno se
divierte y cuando uno juega y les juro
que este es el mejor juego del mundo es
más si usted no estuviera trabajando en
este proyecto de enchufe tv pins lo que
haría en cualquier otro trabajo sería lo
que agua hay adentro
después
entré a la universidad y encontré a
personas con las que compartía esta
misma pasión sobre todo este motor de
hacer cosas que queríamos ver como
espectadores y como espectadores
teníamos una gran necesidad que era que
no teníamos contenido en español que nos
gustara presión para mí eso es gravísimo
porque soy súper malo en el inglés así
que tenemos que hacer algo que ignacio
una premisa que hasta cierto punto puede
estar un poquito grandilocuente pero que
era muy cierta era muy real en su época
y lo sigue siendo solo que en otro nivel
quiera renovar el audiovisual
ecuatoriano ahora es renovar el
audiovisual en español pero en ese
tiempo era renovar el audiovisual local
y de alguna manera como íbamos a hacer
eso si es que uno ve un comercial de
aquí y está súper bien hecho está con
una imagen pulida un sonido super lindo
si las actuaciones no son de modelos que
quieren ser actores está súper bien
como podíamos viendo baile en lobios el
local
y en nuestro ámbito que queríamos hacer
comedia si había muchísimo que hacer la
comedia a la que estamos acostumbrados
desde hace muchísimos años y que ya
habíamos normalizado en una comedia
completamente peyorativa que tenía que
burlarse del otro para poder reírnos y
eso muy fácilmente puede caer en el
racismo en el sexismo en la xenofobia
nuestra propuesta era diferente era
reírnos de nosotros mismos como lo hizo
chaplin como lo hizo cantinflas de su
época hacer una comedia mucho más
vivencial que observacional y así fue
como nuestras peores anécdotas se
terminaron convirtiendo en nuestros
mejores sketchs
y este juego que teníamos cuando era
chiquito se convirtió en un juego real
en un juego con director de fotos reales
con solistas de verdad con actores de
verdad y sobre todo con una audiencia
que espera nuestro contenido
semanalmente este que puede sonar un
poco utópico romántico está esta idea de
que tu sueño de que tu proyecto se haga
realidad pero les juro de verdad de
corazón que es verdad una gran condición
que es trabajar un montón es trabajar
más que nadie es sacarse la madre cuando
no es creer que puedes hacerlo si no
hacerlo entonces tratar de hacerlo si no
hacerlo
no les voy a mentir no le va a salir
bien ni a la primera ni a la segunda tal
vez ni a la tercera pero por favor no
bajen los brazos que puesto que aquí en
estas sillas hay personas con proyectos
brillantes y si es que no hay aquí por
lo menos conocen a alguien afuera que
tiene proyectos brillantes pero no se
les hace como muy comunes
esta frase cuando yo que sé alguien está
caminando por la calle y se encuentra
con alguien que me ha visto en montada
hace años y te dice que fue lo que como
estás tiene aquí hermano tengo un
proyecto y vos
por favor no se conviertan en esa mujer
y en ese hombre proyecto hagan lo
arriesguen se equivoquen se perfeccionen
y vuelvan a equivocarse no se sientan en
su zona de confort
el amor en sede su idea
crean que de verdad es la mejoría del
mundo porque solo así van a poder
enamorar al resto cuando empezamos
éramos cuatro estudiantes de cine
con una cámara de fotos que graba vídeo
una computadora y un sueño enchufe en
realidad nació como un proyecto piloto
para televisión que fue rechazado por
todas las televisoras del país porque
por obvias razones no éramos como
estudiantes inexpertos no tenemos un
aval que nos permite entrar ni palancas
tampoco
así que no se pudo dar nuestro siguiente
paso en teoría por haber estudiado cine
era hacer el gran formato hacer una
película con este mismo contenido para
hacer una película es demasiado caro es
una labor carísima el cine y
lamentablemente no se nos no teníamos
los recursos de inversionistas que se
interesen en nuestro proyecto pero
siempre hay una opción ya no hay excusas
siempre hay opciones
y esta fue el internet el internet que
es un medio completamente democrático
libre de filtros de límites geográficos
gratis en el que podríamos tener como
una relación espectador el espectador y
realizador tan cercana crisis que el
espectador le gustaba el contenido
ponían likes y no le gustaba ponia
dislike cada laica de edad se contaba
nosotros veíamos de eso y nada en la
barra de likes si es que la audiencia
quería dar su pensar acerca del
contenido lo escribe en un comentario y
nosotros podíamos leerlo y así manejar
el timón del contenido que estábamos
haciendo una ventaja por sobre cualquier
medio tradicional
y gracias de dios bueno tuvimos que ir
por ese camino y obviamente teníamos que
tener un lugar donde operar
mi tía tiene una empresa de servicios
empresariales tenía un cuartito donde
tenía usada como bodega sacó todas las
cajas que tenía ahí y metimos la
computadora la cámara y trabajábamos
siete días de la semana escuchando les
miento no exagero siete días a la semana
durante 16 las diarias sin fiestas sin
feriados sin cumpleaños sin salidas
porque creíamos en el proyecto de verdad
creíamos en esto a pesar de que nadie
más creía esto pasó hace cinco años
cuando estábamos empezando nos decían ok
quieren hacer contenido para internet
háganlo háganlo en español digan hagan
inglés todo el mundo consume contenido
en inglés esto pasó hace cinco años y
era verdad
hicimos dos nosotros hablamos de español
queremos hacer un español justamente
porque no existe este tipo de contenido
en español
decían ok a si quieres hacerlo en
español que es en un español totalmente
neutral que se entienda desde españa
méjico pasando por la patagonia era como
ok está bien que se entienda en todas
partes pero por qué no hablar como
ecuatorianos sea la final
los ecuatorianos tenemos una forma tan
bella de hablar que nadie conoce afuera
y por qué no ser igual de valientes que
los argentinos que los mexicanos que los
colombianos que exportaron su par se
escuche su hora le way que nosotros
aportamos nuestro chuta nuestro h
el ride hightower bar mamá yo quise el
rato que yo escuché un chut en mexico es
como poner la bandera en la luna así les
juro
y quiero quiero hacer un paréntesis con
respecto a esta lista me acordé de una
con este vídeo que viene después pero
recordé una cosa que cuando empezamos a
lanzar vídeos
como youtube nos puso en colombia porque
no había no había oficinas de youtube en
ecuador
la gente decía oye qué buenos estos
colombianos no crear esos colombianos de
todas las novelas chistosas si no no no
no son colombiano tienen acento
colombiano decían es verdad que buenos
estos mexicanos
hacer cosas increíbles el 100 no es tan
gran vida eso es quito eso es cuenca de
una pena no estos mexicanos grabando en
cuenta qué buenos que son
y después bueno gracias
qué bueno que me acordé de esto porque
me gane el primer aplauso gracias
y literalmente por ser necios o sea por
hablar como como hablamos por filmar
donde estamos es que ahora somos del
canal de sketches en español más visto
del mundo con más de 15 millones de
suscriptores solo en youtube y más de
100 millones de reproducciones en esta
plataforma sin contar las reproducciones
de en facebook sin contar todo el
contenido que se reproduce en
plataformas tradicionales como comedy
central en toda américa incluyendo
incluyendo brasil enchufe tv está
doblado el portugués de brasil sin
incluir galera la visión que es canal de
cable en eeuu y canales locales como
ecuavisa y latina en perú
y esto y esto y esto es súper lindo
porque un día entró uno de mis
productores a la sala donde estábamos
escribiendo y dijo amigos acaba de
llamar la warner brothers y quieren que
hagamos algo con ellos si los gringos
terminaron llamándonos al al final esto
me lanzó a una historia súper linda que
una vez me contó mi papá después juliana
me di cuenta que era un cuento chino de
un empresario que tenía una empresa de
zapatos muy grande occidental que quería
ver si es que se ponía un está una
sucursal de esta empresa en un lugar
específico de áfrica llama a sus dos
vendedores más fuertes los vendedores de
estrellas
para enviarlos a ver por separado para
enviarlos por separado a ver si es que
era rentable ponerse la sucursal de la
empresa llegó el primer dijo mi jefe
no vayamos vamos a ir a la quiebra ya
nadie usa zapatos dijo bacán chévere
gracias paso llegó el segundo dijo jefe
si vamos nos hacemos millonarios nadie
usa zapatos seríamos los primeros en
vender zapatos ahí creo que la única
diferencia entre estos dos vendedores es
que uno creyó y se lanzó y si es que
algo puedo dejarles hoy es que por favor
crean y se lance muchas gracias
i
[Música]
yo